[Music]
Angus T Jones the actor who plays the
kid on Two and a Half Men had some harsh
words to say about his show and
everyone's talking about this in
Hollywood in a clip that has gone viral
the actor called the show filth urge
people to stop watching it well here
with a response to anguses concerns is
our own Andy Richter Andy Thank You
Conan Angus so you're stuck on a TV show
you personally find beneath you trust me
I know exactly what you're going 9 after
night of being forced to endure a
never-ending parade of Filth thinly
disguised as entertainment
packed with jokes that aren't fit to
clog a bus station toilet yeah I get it
and to make things even more humiliating
you're not even the star of this
televised garbage fire you're just that
chubby half man playing second fiddle to
some lanky overpaid egomaniac with a
bottomless reservoir of neediness the
very sound of his high-pitched shrieking
voice fills you with so much rage takes
every ounce of restraint not to slap
that ridiculous fright wig off his head
well Angus here's my advice to you do
what I do smile nod politely and trudge
onward through the filth and as for
those nagging little things you call
feelings and a personal belief system
well there's a place for those and that
place is hidden deep down inside
yourself where no one not you or your
family or even the shrink you've been
lying to for years will never fight you
wouldn't believe how many feelings you
can fit down there if you shove really
hard thank thank you Andy those were
[Applause]
buddy let's just let's move on with the
show shall we Andy oh all right well
coming up later in the show an all-new
episode of fart police
[Music]
[Applause]
Andy good job thanks Conan